[Music]
what is up fam this is the first ever
live episode of the shop show here on
YouTube thanks for tuning in kiddos
the the thick boy Stafford little pins
and needles especially Casey Chin's a
little high strung go live oh wow your
glasses are missing a hand I know it's
my reading glasses that's why oh yeah I
have my regular ones but it's easier to
see the computer with reading glasses
gotcha yeah right yeah mine was taped
aside he lost it I ordered new ones
they're coming in all right man uh
before he had started college football
fans it is time there was a game uh this
previous weekend this past weekend you
had Notre Dame playing in uh Dublin
Ireland against Navy and they beat the
breaks off of them but that doesn't
count because uh it just doesn't right
so college football kicks off this
freaking Thursday you got Florida Utah
going down and then Friday you got a
bunch of games Saturday you got the big
boy that's the official kickoff of the
real season my CU Buffs are taking on
TCU and listen college football fans are
you ready for week one draftking
Sportsbook is hooking up with a can't
miss offer to start the season strong
this week starts on Thursday this week
new customers can bet just five dollars
on college football and score 200 in
bonus bets instantly Anything Can Happen
college football your team could go from
on-ranked to Dynasty mode in just a
couple of years change comes fast
especially if you got Deon saying
vendors holler at Sea Buffs the only
thing that the only thing that's a lock
is the great offers from my friends at
DraftKings Sportsbook life's more fun
when you're in the action download the
rafkin sports week app right now use
code shop show bet on my CU Buffs to
beat TCU TCU is ranked CU is not we will
see what is up you know that the
freaking C Buffs are going to come out
strong a lot of pressure on it gives me
anxiety but we have more transfers than
any other team in division one football
they're loaded with Talent yeah Deion
Sanders the head coach you got a good
coaching staff Boulder stand up show out
for your team there in CU Boulder all
right new customers can bat all right
new customer can bat on my CU Buffs to
be TCU you can score 200 in bonus bets
instantly when they bet just five
dollars on college football only on
drafting Sportsbook with the coach shop
show the crown is yours go Buffs this is
where it gets dicey when you do read
gambling problem called Wayne hard
Gambler visit www dot 1 800 gambler.net
in New York call 8778 Hope and wiretex
hope NY 467-369 in Connecticut help is
available for problem gambling call
888-789-7777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino Resort in
Kansas 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario c c d k n g
dot Co slash football for eligibility
terms in responsible gaming resources
bonus bets expired seven days after
issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply DraftKings promo code
shop show go Buffs
boom you're nervous about that Jay now a
little bit it's awesome you got to read
it's all good when you got to read the
red tape I want to get you going man all
right welcome kiddos to the shop show
live for the first time ever try not to
cuss all right trying to guess you got
to remember I grew up like the osbornes
if you remember the Osborne's reality
show my family's from England they smoke
they cuss it's what we did so it's
ingrained in My DNA but I will do my
best not because on these live ones
apparently that's frowned upon on here
so we're doing our best fun little
weekend uh with the fam the kids are
going back to school this week so it was
a fun-filled uh weekend you had
Disneyland uh this is in the four day
grace period here yeah Disneyland
Monster Jam
and then we ended the weekend really was
just me and the oldest t mean tiger
ended uh Sunday yesterday at Mario Land
Meyerland a lot of hype you know I grew
up playing Mario uh the Mario game at
the Mario bride at Universal a little
overrated I got no idea a little
overrated you're in the machine's cool
but um that's a giant Homer Simpson
donut after The Simpsons Ride I'm pretty
sure he pooped his pants after that
um so that's cool but
um yeah the my right compared to like
the mummy Jurassic Park uh even The
Simpsons
the production's dope like the the sets
though be like in actual Mario Land and
they have like the moving plants and
Bowser and all that stuff but the actual
ride let me down a little bit like an
idea let me down why because it's
supposed to be Mario Kart but so I
figure you drive your own like shoot the
the shells like the game but you're
actually it's four people in a cart so
you're with people you don't know you
have a helmet on with goggles so it's
like VR and then it's it's all like
like VR like it's it's not better than
your the Oculus that you get at Facebook
you know that Facebook makes like it's
the same thing as that not as fun I
don't know it's just it's out of all
their major rides The Mummy
Transformers uh Jurassic Park and uh
even the Harry Potter ride it's out of
all of them it's probably the worst one
I can lie to you guys it's disappointing
even my son was like yeah I was like you
want we went on it twice and then I was
like is that your favorite he's like no
mommy's my favorite so we want a mommy a
lot which that makes me sick but gotta
be a dad so I have to go on try not to
throw up uh let's get into the fighting
though
and let's get into college football
because my CU Buffs played this freaking
Saturday against TC you come out hot the
expectations on them uh give me anxiety
everyone listen if you're a c buff fan
you follow college football be cool man
be cool I know they have the more most
transfers of any other college football
team they're stacked they have the the
right coaching staff right and there's
all this hype they've sold out damn near
every game they sold out the spring game
their jerseys the merch is selling the
home tickets are selling they're selling
on the road all this stuff remember they
won one game last year one game if Dion
wins five that'd be a significant
Improvement so if they start off two and
two they start off three in one whatever
be cool man the expectation on these
kids are insane insane now Dion brought
about himself but I think we need to be
realistic are gonna be a top 10 team
probably if they are oh my God that'd be
the biggest turnaround college football
history that'd be great but be cool
everybody if they if they if they have a
compare of game against TCU that's
Improvement that's where I'm at we have
expectations here be cool
now hopefully
see puts up a better fight than our boy
Korean zombie put up against Max
Holloway an ultra guy I'm not sure he
did well man he did well it was very if
you're gonna go out on your Shield it's
very Korean zombie he went uh kamikaze
pilot in that third round he really did
man because the first two rounds he
landed some good shots he landed a
really good hook on Max Holloway shows
you Max Holloway's chin obviously Max
always dealing with a lot with the fires
out there in Maui in his home uh state
of Hawaii so heavy heart for Max
Hollywood going into the fight
significant favorite for good reason
um it's insane the career these two have
had that they've never crossed paths
till now you know it's sex with creating
zombie obviously he's on the
you know yeah on the back nine of his
life when I say back time he's on hole
18.
but all the fights he gave us it was
it was such a beautiful thing the the
audience how much the character how much
they loved him what's weird you'll see
this like if you watch one Championship
if you watch a lot of Asian uh
kind of fights right so even the pride
days in one Championship Rising the
crowds aren't as crunk as American or
european crowds they're just not they're
more calculated the more reserved there
are more students of the game they enjoy
Jiu Jitsu they enjoy the ground game
they see the sweet science with all of
it they don't it's rare they boo they
don't really boo people that's not what
they do they're good people they're good
respectable people you're not going to
hear rip his hat off you're not gonna
hear Punch or twist his weiner off stuff
like that not in the Asian crowds the
you know because they're respectable
people
um you know I see a lot of tap out
shirts you're just not but um so when
you know I I did watch most of the card
I'm I probably started off
um I start off probably at the Billy
golf fight
so I miss uh the JJ Aldrich fight I
started with Billy um so it started
pretty sweet with that TK on the first
round
um so I started there which was early
but I'm always up early still didn't
mind it literally cards are nice
um
but the the rest of the card I was like
oh man this ground doesn't seem too into
it slower fights it's been some good
ones the prelims were pretty lit then we
get into the main card uh junior top had
that good knockout and they got decision
decision the Aaron uh blanchfield fight
you know I hear people ask saying Oh
Aaron blanchfield deserves a title shot
after this she's won six in a row we
want to see her against the winner of
Alexa Grosso and chefchenko can you give
someone a title even though they've won
six more can you give him a tile shot
after a performance like that didn't
land a signal take down what you go oh
for 14 on takedown something like that
you know she you know she's won a ton in
a row so I I get her resume
but uh
ah she doesn't you know you don't want
to knock her for this
but usually when people get tile shots
at you and she's on denial at this point
especially winning that minute in a row
and she had you know those huge wins
over uh meatball she submitted her which
was rude
um because we root for meatball here
what she did Jessica and Josh super
impressive uh in the second round with
the submission there she got performance
of the night uh and again Santos she
just couldn't land a takedown I think it
was a good learning experience for us
she went all the rounds kind of down on
scorecards I thought there for a second
um
I you know you look at the division I
could see it but usually you want some
impressive performance a finish or
something like that in order to get
title shot but she might be on denial
about this point and you look at the
rest of the division
um but my point is there is it was just
the crowd
I think it was a little granted it was
early it was a little boring for us here
it was boring for the crowd obviously
they're not going to boo
um so after that fight
um with Aaron uh they had another
decision uh the Giga out uh fight was
entertaining you know Alex did you know
he broke his arm in the first round
defend the kick yeah so that obviously
he was compromised there
um and then with the co-main event
Anthony Smith Ryan span the the rematch
there with Anthony Smith starts from the
first time they fought I guess this one
made sense I thought Anthony Smith you
know what he says 38 I feel like a
little older but great win for him did
you have him win in chin do you have
anything this one was controversial
so dude I think it's 35 I didn't know he
was that young I thought he's 38. no I
thought it was I mean yeah over 50
fights he has a sh yeah that's all of
them his 55 fights for God's sake yeah I
thought any if anything I draw to me
he was he was amazing in the first round
let's do enough draws they just don't
give enough draws yeah I'm I'm okay with
the draw
so he's won I was at one two three four
four as last six he lost two in a row
before this that's Johnny Walker lost a
modern Med obviously his ankle fell off
in that one
um yeah his last win was Ryan span which
was in 2021 he kind of beat the brakes
up in that first round
uh yeah I could see going either way I'm
not too upset about it I thought the
judge was gonna lean towards spam but
obviously I'm a huge Anthony Smith fan
so I'm glad Anthony got the win there uh
Anthony Smith I don't know if you have
in the current events Anthony Smith and
uh Alex Pierre have some issues yeah uh
we'll get to that but Anthony Smith
versus Alex could be a fun fight
I don't know if they're gonna do that
next even though Anthony is coming off a
win
uh for Pierre I mean the the Yuri fights
you just I don't see anything Smith in
Alex fight next it's Yuri Alex or bust
what do we do please yes that's the
fight we all want yeah uh but for Mac
Tollway Korean zombie
um
I don't think Max Hollywood hasn't had a
knockout since 2018.
um but yeah this was the matchup if
you're gonna get a knockout this be the
one Korean zombie was doing well didn't
look bad it didn't look like a guy you
know there's guys like when you see Tony
Ferguson you see the BJ pens of the
world Dio Sanchez when they're at that
point in their career you're like oh
this is a nightmare they just look
completely off I thought Korean zombie
looked pretty damn good
pretty damn good especially for going
out on a shield first two and he would
definitely have the the flashes of the
old Korean zombie and we'd sit there and
bang and him and Max would go at it Max
just a little quicker a little more
calculated a little more technical would
always win in the exchanges and then in
the third round I don't know if there's
some button they push in the corner or
what but they're like it's time to go
zombie mode it's time to go zombie I
think zombie pushed that button he was
like this is it yeah I'm gonna knock him
out and get knocked out and it was
beautiful to watch yeah it was that's
how it should go for him yeah he went
out for the shield how great of a intro
was that when the the zombie oh my god
um
he gets in there and I was like oh
that's that's lit and the crowd the
energy Jeff definitely went up in the
arena and then when he lost you're like
oh this is a I mean I'm huge Max always
fan
um everyone expect to including the
oddsmaker expect him to win gets to walk
off home run KO right and then
um
you know it was about Max for a little
bit he was talking about Hawaii and
donate money and raise money which God
bless him yeah God bless them and then
it went over to Korean zombie and the
Hulk the crowd just the zomb like what a
send-off for the UFC and they're they're
doing it right now yes they they've read
the comments they've seen how much
backlash they've got just you know
whether it's Frank Yeager whoever it is
these guys when it's their last fight
and they're just not giving proper send
off fans don't like that you owe it to
them so they did a great job with Robbie
Lawler that video they had for him
um and then with uh zombie man that was
special yeah and is that this girl who
came to America's wife she's cute man
yeah it's just crying adorable couple
yeah yeah she does not seem like someone
that would date or be with a fighter she
seems so innocent yeah so that must be
super tough for her to be with him and
to see all that stuff happening show
much Korean zombie gear was in the crowd
too dude I mean we rocked it all the
time yes as long as it as long as we
could as long as we could yeah because
it was kind of like
try something used to make it oh at the
very very first the very first one that
was my favorite all time ghost I used to
wear I wear UFC Expo in Boston I wore
that cranes I'm sure all the time it's
my favorite shirt I don't know what
happened to it apparently they didn't
pay him well for my girl probably gave
it away this is my favorite shirt and
then Korean zombie knows we're fans Jay
Park Jay Park sent us a bunch of gear
and it was just it was the heaviest most
thick gear you've ever seen you couldn't
wear it to today's supposed to be 105.
you can wear it today it looked amazing
it was bulletproof yeah it's Kevlar that
is kevlar is bulletproof you know it
looked great though yeah you know you
look good I mean same design as it was
always but yeah they need to switch up
the merch just the material yeah but uh
yeah for so for what's next for Korean
zombie it's over right so he's done and
then for Max Holloway he's in a quite
the predicament he's in quite the the
pickle here because he's beat everybody
in that division who's a contender in
the top uh was that top five there so uh
top four he's beat everybody right so he
beat Arnold Allen he just beat him who's
a raging Contender uh he's beat Ortega
he's beat yeah Rodriguez and then he's
number one obviously a fourth fight with
volkanovsky
ah my fourth fights tough sell but he
did win one honestly he did win one he
didn't get the actual win but he did win
one I know but the the argument there
would be the last one that they did that
was obviously really dominating yeah
yeah that one he made it clear which is
what he needed to do when he's on food
truck that's why I told him I said
listen I know you beat him twice
technically but you got to get over the
max hallway hump in order to become the
on Crown Champion you gotta and that's
what he did
um so a fourth fight I think is tough
fourth fight stuff not to mention
um uh Ilia topiria is going to get the
next uh shot at the champ there when
volkanovsky so that's not even announced
yet so he's gonna have to wait for that
which I don't think he Minds uh he said
he doesn't mind beating up the
contenders either he doesn't mind at all
being of the contenders uh most of uh at
10 probably the next guy
but for Matthew number one you wanna
fight the number 10 guy I don't see much
of an upside and you're just waiting
what what the best case is there for Max
there's two what I think there's two
options if I'm his management uh today
this morning we're looking at this
you're going all right
we need topiri to win if topir wins then
you'd fight Ilya that's a fight I'd love
that fight yeah that's an amazing fight
Chancellor winning not good so what if
that does if volkanovski is who he says
he is he probably beats the [__] out of
topirio right so you're probably not
getting the UFC probably didn't do a
fourth fight for you so do we take six
to eight months put on a little bit of
weight and uh go end up and remember Max
always older now too do we go up to 55
there's fun matchups of 55. now as
you're listening she's gonna do we saw
that remember we flat doesn't pour it he
would land a lot but before he just uh
poorly just hit harder so it didn't work
out for Max I get that but he didn't
technically have enough time to put on
the size and weight I'm talking Jon
Jones down not two three years but eight
months 12 months take your time put on
the weight see how you feel and then
really make a run at 55.
for anybody but uh there's some fights
there just in case you'd be fun I'd
watch Poirier again der you should good
one Chandler's good one you wouldn't
watch Max Hollywood versus uh physique
maybe beautiful phenomenal fight
I just think there's more upside and
you're not at his age and you're and all
the fights he's been in you're not
coming down to you know 45 55
you know it's not like he's a small 45er
so I think if you took the time you get
the right team around you he could have
a lot of success at 55 is he gonna be is
he going to become champ uh Mark Chesney
nightmare for anybody but uh there's
some fun fights with Charles Olivera
there at 55 Justin gaichi does Emporia
again Darius is fun Chandler for zeev
those are top six big big names big
fights or you hang out at 45 you hope
toparia wins which most likely is not
going to if he does all good forget this
55 talk but you can fight till Perry if
he beats bokonafsi it's a big if and if
you don't want to do any of that you can
stick around and fight the you know the
young contenders coming up we saw what
we did to Arnold Allen the fight wasn't
close
for the UFC it's not good either if he
just sits around and beats up these
young Lions who are kind of the next
wave of that division you don't want Max
to always just sit around be this
gatekeeper he's gonna beat all of them
and then you gotta hope eventually
somebody beats Max or Alex wilkinowsky
which they're not going to so he's in a
weird spot
he's gonna wear a spot oh I ran in Jon
Jones oh yeah I saw the picture I
haven't been in studio since I ran into
Jon Jones random Jon Jones so John and I
were at the JW Marriott in downtown L.A
so he's sponsored by monster I'm
sponsored by rain uh body fuel
both energy drinks right and so monster
owns rain so they have their once a year
they do their annual sales meeting like
so just so you know I didn't know this
either monster is a 60 billion dollar
company
60 billion dollar company so they have
five thousand Nationwide or [__] there's
people all over worldwide uh sales team
so they fly in all five thousand people
to one location you just in Vegas this
year they did in LA and then they have
keynote speakers they have appearances
for all the the employees so that's why
me and John were there they brought me
John a bunch of other talent that they
have on the roster me and John ran each
other I haven't seen John a hot second
uh and we're in the lobby and he grabs
me I didn't see him he grabbed me and uh
shot for a single leg
um but yeah I absolutely loved and dude
he's in shape he's lost weight oh really
lean me you saw him in person yeah dude
that's why I told him I said dude you
look freaking phenomenal like he's just
more trim uh he he's doing the opposite
of what Stipe is doing so steepe's
putting on weight you know to compete
against John and I think I think it's a
mistake but uh and John's going down
he's getting more lean more trim he's
gonna let his uh skill set do the
talking there was good to see you man I
told him I said you know I said this on
the show multiple times I said do you
remember what you did to the
heavyweights like and again I don't name
the names you know that's their stories
to tell but there's five heavyweights in
the gym on training in training two of
them were on cocaine they're impossible
to beat up and then three of us were at
the time ranked in the top ten in the
world and we would do shark tank rounds
so John stays in there to get ready for
the fight and he hits a fresh guy every
round it's called The Shark Tank and it
would be five heavyweights five rounds
you know because he's getting ready for
a top fight and he'd beat the brakes off
all of us not even close
I'm like he's always been trading with
heavyweights he's too he's too good to
train with anybody not at a heavyweight
so he needed the challenge and he would
mop the floor with us so now he's doing
heavily it's not surprising I've always
said this he's an absolute monster
asked him about his retirement if he
beats steepe in New York his hometown if
he can retire
seems like it interesting seems like it
seems like it but yeah it was good to
see you man he's such a beast
what do you got for me Jen uh first
before we go to current events how about
some happy hippo
you want some happy hippo
you want some happy able to get your
mind right yeah all right well let's
let's get everybody's mind right with a
little happy hippo help you get that
brain right all right uh I use this
product for every show that I do any
podcast I do a million podcasts any
stand up I'm always using happy hippo
however you want to get your stuff uh
they even have k-dips this is kratom in
uh dip form this is Wintergreen of the
Razzle Dazzle 20 milligrams of pure
kratom in each pouch I love them they
got the the high concentrated Sour Apple
Shots which I love too they got gummies
they got powders everyone to get your
freaking happy hippo into that brain we
got you covered uh it gives you that
nice warm balance good mood feeling get
your brain fired up for the day all
right
um there this is my Hidden Gem if you go
to happyhippo.com promo code thick
that's t h i three C's 23 you save 20
for Life share with a friend Uber driver
Postmates Uber whatever it is UPS guy
you all get at 20 off for life when you
use the promo code thick23 at
happyhippo.com
let's get back to the program
I usually you have to always say that
but now we're live you're seeing it live
yeah well go live effort we'll do it
live
so this is just a post from the Korean
zombie after the fight that's his wife
in the background he's in the hospital
so he basically just said that
he hasn't achieved he wanted to be
Champion right that's that's his whole
goal but he wasn't he had a shot though
good career though man yeah so he's like
he doesn't want to hang your head on
that stuff dude I would want this type
of like career if when zombie was a kid
we're like hey man your fight Jose Aldo
right you have this ridiculous career
you can pull off a twister you're you're
gonna fight uh Jose Aldo you fight
Alexander volkanovsky for the the title
at UFC you're not gonna win but still
you're right there and you list all the
guys that he's fought all the big wins
The Knockouts the merch becoming a fan
favorite he must be massive in Korea a
massive in Korea and just in Asia even
just all of Asia so yeah so this from
Chris zombie this is from his Instagram
but I haven't achieved everything but
I've achieved enough and wanting more in
my head is like greed so I'm trying to
stop
um translate through Google so bear with
us this is how I talk in general
whatever I feel like I've received
undeserved love compared to what I've
done so I'm grateful to everyone now I
don't think I will live a lot uh live a
life of I was about to say I almost said
I thought you said I feel like I'm not
going to live a long life I'm like okay
it's getting dark I'll just get really
dark I will live a life of being judged
impaired anymore so I feel free relieved
and scared I understand that to the
fullest buddy uh in the meantime thanks
so much for loving Korean zombie I was
really really happy while fighting the
UFC thank UFC Sean Shelby Dan White for
let me live this life it was an honor
for Max Holly to be my last fight
opponent let's greet each other with a
bright smile someday hashtag and yeah
[Music]
she's all shy huh yeah and then Max
posted about him too which I thought was
super awesome of them this is what I
love about Mac so we live in this great
dude the best yeah the best he's a
champion through and through so is
volkanovsky there's certain guys that
you see now
dunking around for what I do especially
that this job like you know with news
and current events and breaking news
stuff like that and there's the Logan
Paul's and Dylan danis's and the Sean
stricklands and you know these people
that talk all this stuff and that toxic
environment that social media encourages
and this this very toxic world we live
in with the with its YouTube comments or
Instagram comments or Twitter comments
and people get attention from being
negative there's guys like Max Holloway
there's guys like Korean zombie there's
guys like Alex Alexander volkanovsky
there's guys like this that exist who
don't do that stuff they don't subscribe
to it and they still have huge names and
so a lot of merch people pay for their
pay-per-views they're they're still you
know big names in the sport without
going that direction it's it's so rare
unfortunately it's so rare and so rare
you know
it's a very beautiful thing though it's
cool that that still exists yeah
so yeah he basically just said you know
he was one of he's one honors Sherlock
done with you Korean zombie the man the
myth the legend watching throughout the
years how he carries stuff in the fight
world with humility and respect like a
true martial artist the ogs of WC and
UFC none of these circus acts there you
go now these circus acts You're The Last
of a Dying Breed boy is he right thank
you for Paving the way enjoy your
retirement looking forward to your first
singing album he does sing pretty well
dude oh he sings yeah he sings
we can't play any videos of it but he
does seem pretty demo it's like
Americans go from fighting to YouTube
and like these weird like fights and
Koreans going to sing it yeah dude
watching something Korean sing dude I
don't know so Koreans and Filipinos of
all the Asians they're like to me the
best singers of the Asian people
interesting yeah
that's dope yeah
so that's super cool to see man please
write Last of a Dying Breed it's just
now these days if you want attention you
talk the most toxic stuff and you you
create all this weird toxic hype and
hate and he gets attention so of course
I get it these young kids are like yeah
that's that's what we got to do you know
and I think the the tension is kind of
short-lived when they do the bad stuff
but this kind of attention is long
lasting forever I'll always like respect
these guys and and you know dude cherish
all the stuff that Zombie's done and
reacts too like yeah don't say cherish
yeah don't say cherished I knew as soon
as I said
yeah
go upstairs
we were on our group chat with the
fights I was like this is such a
beautiful thing this is so amazing yeah
I just thought you were being a little
gay because you were because you were
camping and you're drinking I was like
yeah I'll let you have this a little bit
more in the emotions we have some sips
but yeah yeah it was beautiful it was 7
A.M and you're drinking
so I let that go the group chat I was
like oh Chen's in his feelings right now
Chin's like what a chip we should all
cherish this moment man I was like
murder these fish and drink Seven shots
of whiskey man this is such a good warm
feeling sip it up man
I just went with the boys huh just one
of my buddies yeah yeah that's cool hell
yeah
uh so this kind of made headlines
recently so uh Conor McGregor screenshot
this and apparently so there's other
media Outlets that cover this and showed
this too so this is apparently on like
the landing page of USC fight pass but
why would you have to announce this on
Fight Pass I don't know that's why I
don't even know how where you even find
this I feel like some employee really
messed up which happens it does happen
so yeah because remember they announced
that one fight on the teams
yeah yeah so it says UFC 296 Chandler
versus McGregor 9 p.m Saturday December
16th
and that shows like the day's hours it
actually has to count that looks
official and Connor retweeted it or
posted it Connor blasted it out but the
UFC hasn't said anything no
I don't see I I bet encountered you know
does a you know does his thing to beat
up his own drum so that's why if it was
anybody else like yeah this is garbage
but when it's Conor there's they can't
do anything to him there's no
repercussions this guy clearly does
whatever he wants so usually like hey
man let's be the first announce he's
like say less posted
it's weird it was on Fight Pass it makes
sense that they're doing it
I think it's gonna
I'm I'm conflicted because a lot of it
it's like it doesn't McGregor fight
again like if you saw Darren till he's
like he's never fighting again you know
this guy's office Rock he's never fine
again hopefully he does but uh I like to
think it's gonna happen it has to be
Chandler it has to be Chandler
Casey's the biggest McGregor fan and you
and I won a1b McGregor fans do you think
you think there's truth to it I think
it's going down yeah yeah 100 so cases
is yes I say yes you say yes in case
scissors my initial reaction was like no
but this year December
I think so that was the plan right
and he does get his way so
there's nobody more powerful in the UFC
if that's what he wants to do and when
he came out with the comments with those
Voice Notes too
he's the only guy can move make moves
like this yeah when he says jump the UFC
says how high sir
he's the only guy
and we all want to watch it so I don't
testing steroids I one leg dude get him
in there
sign me up take my money
all right um
a quick little boxing one so uh music
Alexander yusick fought Daniel Dubois
over the weekend and then there's
controversy even though he won he won
low blow knockout yeah the low blow and
I'll show you the picture here this I
think this is his coach or manager
that posted this or he was in the post
fight press conference and he showed
this picture and he's like hey so what
is considered a a legal shot and
apparently if it's under you know if
it's hitting the shorts under that
waistband whatever even though it
doesn't really hit his
dick so much say weiner maybe the top of
his wiener yeah yeah he probably does
graze the top of his wiener but it's
still considered a low blow I'm sorry
yeah it's still considered a low blow so
he should still depends how big that
Ukrainian wiener is though right
I mean if it's like high up on near his
belly or something yeah it's on the Belt
Line yeah I don't know it looks but I
mean this is I guess in boxing this is
considered a low blow regardless even if
it's his stomach yeah it's underneath
that waistband thing and on the shorts
so that's what his coach or whatever it
was saying so Dubois gonna appeal the
decision yeah that never works also
you're never gonna beat that guy but
also did you see when uh Fury jumped to
the ring started talking trash USIC and
usic's just staring through his soul no
you see that yeah no fury is like yeah
just you know doing what Fury does best
just real gift of the Gap just going
going uc's just staring through his soul
he's like dude my country's at War you
know he's just such a Savage
it'd be heartbreaking if we don't get
using first Fury you guys know this well
Dykeman here's my favorite Combat Sports
athlete of all time that usick fight is
a tough one
yeah even nusic's haircuts gangster good
God you think USIC would ever wear a
freaking
hat like this
I think he would actually oh dude if he
has that kind of haircut I think he
would are you talking about that
Apocalypto Ukrainian haircut
Steve Austin
and even this haircut looks great
got it even if you know I'm not the
biggest wrestling fan I don't mind it I
don't hate on it I'm just it's I'm just
not into it if my kids get into it I'd
get into it more but uh
Hulk Hogan on Rogan's fantastic oh I'm
not even into wrestling with his stories
I'm sure how Holly how Vince McMahon had
the idea because I guess there's like
territories in wrestling especially back
in the 80s I think 80s maybe 70s but uh
there's like territories where you're
they have their promotion and nobody
else is allowed to cross that territory
and Vince McMahon told Hulk Hogan's like
we're gonna We want this thing
Nationwide we're gonna go in those
territories you down and Oakland's like
yeah let's do it what's the worst kid
happened dude it got dicey when the
promoters came with a gun pulled a gun
on Hulk Hogan uh he's saying like the
Dominican Republic uh one dude cut the
other dude's throat like it gets dark
cut his throat yeah dude crap yeah nuts
yeah
the Hulk Hogan said he's had so many
surgeries on his back he used to be six
seven nice six four
because I've taken out so much of his
voice disc holy crap you get definitely
an appreciation for wrestling unless
you're like oh yeah
like when people say it's fake yeah it's
all it's scripted yeah it's pre-scripted
but
as far as the the actual physical toll
yeah it's real
yeah the dude Logan Paul he what how
many MCL or ACL or some issues he had
he's been wrestling for like two weeks I
know Harry blew out his ACL and MCL
I'm pretty sure he did we're talking
some real WWE stuff here Jane you bring
up Logan Paul it's the only guy you can
think of huh yeah
out of all the guys because it's current
man yeah I guess man yeah he's
impressive what he's doing yeah ah no I
don't know technical WB wrestling
but I assume it's good I see him doing
backflips they keep booking him he
looked amazing his acrobat we don't know
wrestling though right but I saw him
jump off the damn the whatever the ropes
and then slammed into a table and the
guy it looked impressive to me yeah I
mean I see singers on Instagram like I
can sing if I show you like that guy
can't sing you know it's like that's
what let's talk about WWE right now I
mean I guess he did a flip that's good
yeah
all right I'm not I don't know yeah we
don't know it looked cool to me name
another guy Hulk Hogan name one more
Rowdy Roddy Piper back in the day all
right because of Ronda Rousey
there you go
um oh wait so there is a current event
about Ron Rousey so I guess someone
asked Dana White again about Ronda
Rousey he's like no it's not happening
for sure even though she's not in the
WWE anymore she won the championship but
then the person that wrote the article
said when's the last time has Dana ever
white ever lied about something like
this before about a big Superstar coming
back was he and he was asking a serious
question no no the writer of the article
said like he's like does he know the UFC
is he saying why would Daniel says he's
never done this before he's basically
joking like oh God would he lie to us of
course he would lie to us I'll say this
I've won good authority
good authority they offered Ronda Rousey
more money than you can imagine to come
back and she said no oh crap so there
were times it's not it's not a yeah and
it's like uh it's like the guy that
can't get the hot girl like she's ugly
okay that's like Daniel's Dan's like no
dude we never offered her she's not
fighting
uh now maybe Dana didn't do the deal I'm
not saying Dana offered it from what I
know that after more money than God and
she's like I'm good
she's Ron is very smart has other
businesses her Farms her houses like she
doesn't need to do any of it she said no
but I heard that for her more money than
God to come back and fight and she said
no
I mean that would be massive if she if
she actually came back I think she beats
Pena
oh
damn chin took a guess I did cherish
that dude
I knew it since as soon as a church
and that soft on his dung a little bit
here's a quick one so Stephen Thompson
you know how Dana White said that uh
Dana offered Aaron gear uh Ian Gary
Stephen Tom or offered Stephen Thompson
Ian Gary and then he denied it right
away because Stephen Thompson he wants a
full cam he's like I'm down to fight
those guys the Ian Gary and he's done it
the Jack uh
jdm's yeah he was like I'm down to fight
any of those guys I just want a full
Camp yeah
he's done he's done it before he's done
it before he's 40 now he loses another
one gets tough for him to to make a run
at the title which is what he wants
that's why I said for tomorrow to call
me out let's do it he's I'm in 100. yeah
it's a very tough fight which makes him
look even Wonder Boy Camaro would be a
would be a fun fight
but he said he's down I wonder what the
UFC's gonna do because Camaro he has
enough leverage we could call shots and
fight a Wonder Boy
um I wonder what the FC is gonna do
because Ian Gary Wonderboy makes a lot
of sense especially
let's just call it um this is no shade
on anybody that I'm gonna mention here
but let's say you own a business
how many more fights does Camaro have
you think
two
how many how much more of a run does
Wonder Boy have
a lot maybe two certainly two two how
many more fights does Ian Gary have how
many more fights does uh Jack have
so if I'm the UFC
I mean depend what you want to do there
you know I I don't you know Camaro and
and wonder boys have their run they've
had their time I'm probably gonna invest
in the in Gary's of the world and the
jdm's of the world and we go no no no no
no uh Wonder Boy cool you're not
fighting Kamal you two older guys aren't
fighting we need to build up the the
younger crop Ian Gary's the next Guy
Wonder Boy and Gary that's the fight you
know
that'd be the fight that's what I would
do as a business now as far as what I
would love to see Camaro and Wonder Boy
fight I love both those guys that'd be a
phenomenal fight but if I own the
business I'm doing Ian Gary and Wonder
Boy I think Inger beats uh Wonder Boy I
think Aaron Gary beats Camaro
damn that's how high I'm on Ian Gary
that was a hot take because Casey just
wrote it down
he's off
he's got highlights it dumbass
check this out dumbass
so if you're the FC you give him the
time to do his full training camp then
right I say cool you'll fight and gear
on a full Camp here's Ian Gary in
December
and that'd be great I'm all in on Ian
Gary from the UFC
you got to build your next star one of
the boys the Stars
rocked it as high can't as high as it
can tomorrow as high as it can
now it's time to put that rocket ship on
Ian Gary
off the names of these guys
that's the UFC model not mine I'm not
hating on anybody here not throwing [__]
at anybody I'm saying from Biz
standpoint I would protect Ian Gary Yeah
by protect him I mean give him Wonder
Boy which is an easy fight but I think
he beats him give him tomorrow next
okay you two are gonna fight each other
no no so our plan is Wonder Boy you're
gonna fight Ian Gary now I think
tomorrow you're gonna fight him after he
wins that
yeah beats big names and there he goes
yep that's the formula
um all right this is about more of a
I don't know it's still MMA related but
more like you know anyway so Sean
O'Malley was on Bradley Martin's podcast
but it was at Sean O'Malley Studio I
believe and then he was talking about
how he's like a king and he I think him
and his girl do have sort of an open
relationship
yeah but the girl probably doesn't
really obviously like it that much so
so he said that he's a king and he pays
for everything so he should be able to
do this and that you know have enough
relationship have sex every now and then
with another woman and the reason why I
bring this up is because uh Vitor
Belfort came at him hard after that
statement
and I'll show you what Vitor wrote here
I mean if my wife looked like vetores
I'd be saying the same thing you ever
seen her she's yeah she's done uh this
is uh Vitor talking to her reading
reading this deeply saying to me it's
just starting to see that main Professor
end up with multiple Ex-Wives due to
such behaviors was not his wife uh you
serve as a negative role model for this
generation there's some
there's something if it's an open
relationship I don't see the problem
with it you know I'm saying if he's
straight up just like I don't see why
coming out talking about it
oh why he does I don't see that I don't
know I don't know why he would do that
baby let's get more chicks
I don't think that matters actually yeah
yeah yeah uh he serve as a negative role
model for this generation I generally
hope that one day you reflect upon your
change this is terrible Behavior I I
don't mind it the issue is when you have
kids when there's kids involved it gets
a little dicey when you do that stuff uh
but who knows if that's their agreement
who cares that's my third agreement
here's my thing
does it matter
who cares if his agreement with his girl
is open relationship even though they
have a kiddo and it's working for them
do you man
it's not a buddy who has five
girlfriends
and it was a nightmare there's a reason
why you don't do that
unless you're a Hugh Hefner and that
didn't end well again they're canceling
that guy left and right even though he's
dead they're still handsome
it just never works out do you know
anybody in the history of mankind who
did an open relationship where they've
had multiple wives or girlfriends you
know the homeboys at the show on
freaking uh
the show used to be all about them and
the the Sister Wives and all that and
the kids and they had you know four
houses all next to each other so he just
jumped from one house to one house you
know what the show is now
them getting divorced them hating them
the whole Show's I just don't see how it
works I don't I don't see how it's tough
enough with one dude let alone imagine
five bro you're not Phil Jackson you
can't handle these you can't handle all
these freaking personalities that guy
with the long wet Jerry curl Mormon
that's not gonna work out dude
it has to be confusing for the kids too
I realized that that man who lacks
respect for his wife and mother of his
children can never be a good father
remember vitro is also very religious so
it's clearly frowned upon but also who
lacks respect to his wife and mother I
don't have to lack of respect he's young
these young kids are wild it's what they
do if she's cool with it who knows what
if it works for him again and then they
who cares it's their relationship if it
works for them who cares but also here
and here's where the caveat I would love
to punch your ugly face in boxing match
there you go that's why he's doing it
that's never happening your Uncle Dana
White will never let be possible but all
the women would purchase the
pay-per-view to see the whooping I will
give you hashtag disappointed hashtag
role model hashtag
I still use hashtags
gosh
fatherhood and respect I don't know it
was just an interesting but also he's an
old he's an older dude religious dude
like for like to him this is insane to
talk about it you don't make Fighters or
entertainers you know in open marriages
or open relationships yeah it's it's
weird for that this is a thing like who
can if that works for sugar and his
girl's cool with it I don't get why you
guys have any interest in this I never
understood that
the Will Smith and Jada Pickett whole
thing okay
it worked for you guys you've been
together for 30 years and that worked
for you okay
that that like that that would be like
being upset that they have pizza every
Thursday night okay
I don't care
who gives a crap that's what works for
you okay
and you're not forcing on me okay
I don't get why we care
it's different than what we do okay and
how's it going with what you're doing
everything's okie doke in your world
worry about yourself I don't okay
I don't care
I hear and to your point the the whole
like just making it public even the
Jenny Pinkett Will Smith stuff like
that's fine if that you want to do that
go ahead but making it public
in public I don't get the benefit of
that there's no people so more people
want to do it to make it the norm I
don't know why do you care that's not
your job that's your if the Sugar's
thing I mean granted now sugar has a
podcast and one of the reasons we love
him is he's open and honest about this
stuff cool
I you know I just don't see the upside
maybe again more checks I don't see why
he'd go public with this yeah especially
especially when the kiddos involved
these kiddos can be able to hear this
stuff kid's gonna feel bad yeah yeah
all right moving on
um so Alec Alejandro Pantoja uh
apparently he and Sean O'Malley used to
spar way back in the day right
and then uh pantosa just called out uh
O'Malley on his Instagram story
again this is the thing to do I doubt
pantos really wants this but okay if
that's something that's making me want
to go to bandweight it's this guy he
talks too much he talks a lot of smack
if you know about this guy who recorded
my sparring with him and he never said
to me you know why yeah so he's
insinuating that he did better in
sparring but then O'Malley called around
and said like if you want I have the
footage I knocked him out in the first
round oh wow so if you want me to put it
out there I will but then O'Malley also
admitted that uh he was sparring a lot
of people before he got to pantosia so
he was super tired and that third round
pantosia did choke him out but so yeah
hold up he got knocked down the coach
like get up man apparently here's some
water get back in there
bad coaching
I mean yeah
so there's a little beef there going on
but uh this is also old like uh again
Real Housewives is the Ultimate Fighting
Championship here I mean does he forget
how it played out I would say in the
third round he choked me but dude I was
like 1-0 or 2-0 as a pro he's coming off
The Ultimate Fighter make his UFC debut
two weeks out from the UFC do debut I
was effing smoking joints the night
before just like not expecting Henry
sueded him rolling to the gym write my
name down for two rounds so I'm gonna
have to spar this dude two rounds in a
row not in Camp not in shape finish him
in the first round
they're effing pissed Spar him again and
second round I'm 100 gassed out from
already whooping his butt O'Malley
continues by Henry's yelling we want him
for three we want him for three in the
video I'm not sure if you can hear it
but maybe you can Henry was saying hold
off on the punches like you said I was
punching too hard Ben Henderson in the
corner for the second and third round
young they don't come into this gym we
don't get effing tired and I gas the F
out so he does Chuck me out in the third
this has got to be 2015. this is a long
time ago yeah I don't care for 2015.
yeah super super long time ago talking
about two different I mean sugar had one
fight also we talking about sparring
we're talking about practice
we're talking about practice they're
both Champs now
pantosia has more work to do at uh
fly away yes
the thing to do
call out the guys
um so Tony Ferguson posted this recently
that he's not done fighting
and that's his post right here he uses
so many hashtags and he does like
capital letters for each word which it
must be exhausting not done fighting
that takes a lot of time yeah it does
you have to go like a raise capitalize
yeah not done fighting champ
uh CSO then a lot of emojis a lot of
hashtags when he tweets thanks to my box
kill trainer Marvin forgive me right
hashtag lacing up my favorite ones Emoji
Emoji Emoji hashtag F your retiremental
retiremental Emoji Emoji hashtag casuals
and so since this post uh Josh Thompson
I can play this is on his Instagram so I
think we're good to go we should be all
right so let me just play what he said
this is Josh Thompson basically pleading
with uh Ferguson to retire let me see it
I heard he gets choked up a little
emotional yeah why
it's it's still tough but I care for the
guy I care for all these Fighters why
have a nice long look in the mirror with
myself after I lost to him you need to
figure out what you want to do with life
because it's coming to an end real quick
yeah I didn't think it was coming doing
it just went the distance on a split
decision lost to Benson Henderson was
the Champ for a long time then lost a
very narrow Split Decision lost to Bobby
green who I should have lost to I was
out there Molly gagging then I got
destroyed by Tony Fergus and I'm doing
I'm saying this directly to Tony is that
you're going to notice things in your
brain you're going to notice things in
your the way you talk to people the way
you talk to your wife the way you talk
to your kids the way you the way you
handle yourself you need to have a
reality check I can't even explain it
you have to understand how to reel it in
well you're explaining in charge of your
mentality and your and your body
language and the words that come out of
your mouth that can affect your
relationships with everyone I've had
these conversations with myself a lot
there's times where words come out of
your house and it's you don't realize it
and so I get nervous for him watching
him take these else it becomes a little
emotional it's it's a it's a little
[__] up but I care for the guy
he's like speaking from the heart you
could tell to like yeah he's dealing he
must be dealing with his own stuff as
well
yeah
cherish those moments
mm-hmm
yeah I think the toughest thing for a
guy like Tony who's a absolute Warrior
you're talking about like Apocalypto
Vibe like a guy who was born to fight
it's tough for them to walk away it's
just what they love they love nothing
more even more so than their family is
fighting it's just what they do it's
what they're known for it's what they
subscribe to it's all that they know and
it's tough to to walk away
but Josh doesn't say anything we're not
all thinking shout out to Josh Thompson
he's gonna take some heat from Tony's
Never Gonna probably do his podcasts or
you know if he sees him he might you
know who knows what he's gonna do
um you know so it's shout out to Joshua
doing that takes a lot of balls to do
that but these guys are gonna do what
they want to do I I really think it's up
to the UFC
it's on them they should have some sort
of structure in their business plan
where if a guy is
starting to tail off they don't offer me
more fights because would Tony want to
fight if it was in the FC if it was in
Bellator and on the bfl let's say no
let's say a commission goes this guy's
too compromised can't fight in the
majors
you know because other sports do this
no compromise not playing in the majors
would Tony do this in you know bringing
a fire LFA is he still down for does he
like to fight that much where he doesn't
care if it's not in the Big Show
I think there has to be some sort of
commission needs to come and go no more
you've lost one two three four five six
in a row
think about that in 2019 Tony Ferguson's
record was 25 and 3. yeah
now he's 25 and 9.
yeah
tough drop off man tough tough very
tough something happened for sure I mean
it just yeah when you see something
happen yeah he just got older he's at
his freaking over 35 fights
that's what happened he catches up with
it doesn't matter who you are
it's a bummer it sucks to see but this
is just what we sign up for you know
yep okay
um so Junior dos on test we saw pictures
of him on the last episodes how Jackie
is now so he was talking to morning
combat which is you know uh Brian
Campbell Luke Thomas love those guys
yeah they're funny and then
so it's funny how he says this to them
so he's like I'm putting in great work
right now we're not going through asada
it's been great because I could take my
pre-workouts I can take my
my burning fat
this is yeah my burning fat I could take
my all the supplements that I couldn't
before because if you saw it he's
basically saying that he can take
steroids but he's saying that by
pre-workouts yeah my burning fat pills I
take all the supplements I can before
steroids bud and great hell yeah dude
that's what I I love it it's like the
pride days produce some of the best
fights of all time there's nothing
better than Peak Pride days and this is
what our boy Jorge Mazda law is bringing
back now it's bare knuckle MMA
it's gonna be brutal in a great way
yeah I'm excited for it
um so this is kind of cool so Michael
Venom page was on freestyle Bender which
is adesanya's YouTube page but then I
guess his autos on his brother is the
one that interviewed him on that YouTube
page so you're saying like he's
definitely he's definitely down to be in
the UFC obviously and he says if he gets
in the UFC he wants no less than a top
five top ten opponents roughly so like
Michael Chandler yeah UFC's gonna do
that yeah they're not yeah they're not
going to let you Coast through
but he still doesn't sign with UFC right
no I think they must be in like
conversations uh negotiations he says
can I see myself there 100 regards to
joining the UFC they said this on real
style freestyle Benders YouTube page
great content there by the way uh I want
a top five top 10 Macs I don't feel like
I need to prove myself over again agree
100 I just wanted to go on there and
we've seen it with Michael Chandler went
in there fought a top 10 Dan hooker
great first win for him uh that just
sprung him into the top contention that
is the route I see myself in I don't see
any other way I don't need a warm-up
fight it's not like I've been out of the
game for ages I'm ready to go now agree
100 yeah and that division right now
like there's so many fun fights for him
I got one yeah Ian Gary
that would be perfect
dude right there that would be perfect
boom
Ian's what 11 so just outside the 10 but
he's really a top five guy probably
I mean his name alone I'm sure he'll
take that fight yeah if he would
definitely take that fight that'd be
sick hell yeah
dude in Dublin
that'll be awesome also this was
interesting too so max Holloway was on
flagrant with Andrew Schultz and then uh
he was saying like you know because Max
has never been dropped right never yeah
in the UFC so he was saying the one time
he was actually rocked was by of all
people Andre Feely oh interesting
bees back in the day yeah he's still
he's still awesome but yeah so Andre
feely fight Max always said on the
flagrant podcast gonna say a lot of
people would watch and be like doesn't
pray fight second does supporting fight
it was like he never got dropped but I
hear people say the fence saved him
because I was going back but like okay
we were talking about make believe okay
let's effing make believe and my wings
came out we're talking about make-belief
land the cage is there for a reason
um
uh do I get hit and I knew the cage was
going to have my back to her later with
Andre feely I remember getting hit one
time and cracked me something I don't
even know what the heck what he hit me
with I was looking at the scoreboard it
was in Baltimore and I was looking at
the time I was thinking what the hell am
I doing right now I was looking at the
time why am I looking at the time I
should be looking at this guy that's
probably one of the time fewest times
ever
yeah so of all people Andre feely wow
would you guess that um he's awesome
yeah for sure but I wouldn't guess that
for the hardest hitter because he's
faced some hard ass hitters yeah
sometimes just depends where it lands
yeah the Korean Zombie Land a good left
hook I was like yeah that should wobble
nope yeah
uh this is just a quick video
I just saw Chris DeStefano at pfl
well I saw this
man I'm loving it don't tell my mom
all your boys are getting into like MMA
all right listen it's no credit to me
it's it's Rogan he's a guy that was the
first ever to make you know obviously
mixed martial arts in comedy so I think
it's guys just following suit I mean you
look at when you know if you look at
Schultz [__] four years ago you never
had an MMA he never talked MMA didn't
have MMA gay on yeah now he has you know
the guy's on
I think it's because of you dude you
saved Rogue but I'm pretty sure it's
because of you you're the actual MMA guy
you were actually in MMA yeah Theo for
sure obviously mean Theo are very close
so Theo got into MMA
deals post man just still drive me nuts
this is Twitter things yeah you'll see
yeah
uh here's a quick one this is a little
weird but I guess
this is after 292 so Andre Andre
petrossi is our boy what a hater though
apprehends the man who was attempting to
Mask wait wait there's a reason why is
there kids yes they said his team now
he's a hero yeah so him and his team
we're seeing this guy apparently
masturbating while there was kids
present and I guess the guy was
masturbating because of the kids oh no
no they stopped him yeah
okay I thought
before I didn't contact him I thought
some dude off it's two in the morning
driving through Nebraska he's trying to
bust enough or gets back on this
eight-hour drive to Missouri and uh they
stopped them from masturbating that's
not the case here this guy was getting
off the kids they should have killed him
yeah who knows a little backstory here
we got this man masturbating the
children in the bathroom good God it
turned out he took an Uber to the
service area on this Turnpike to do this
worst part humidity doing this
frequently it's sad that he will get
away with this but hopefully we're able
to inspire more people to stand up and
take action
let me see the video oh we can't see the
video
by the way video sucks it's just
basically him being um talked to by the
guys the guys are cussing this guy's
wieners closer there no no there's no
nothing about the actual masturbation
part it's just like the ending part oh I
was hoping that he was like hunched over
jacking it and then Andre just double
likes him from can you imagine they
caught him in the act that because I'd
be sick
uh here's another thing break this is
breaking apparently so Dana White is
offering 2 500 bucks for someone for
someone to find out who this guy is that
tried to break into his house
that's
like when the rock gave his body double
uh F-150
here's Dana White here's the video
he's just kicking the door trying to
kick the door in
if
it hits the camera
so this F face just tried to kick my
front door in in Maine
I will pay two dollars to the first
person to let the police know where he
is
yeah
I'm sure someone's like I could use that
wrap this dude out it's in Maine though
you know Levant mean the finals I bet
it's nice out there I bet Dana goes
there in the summer oh I bet that's nice
have you been to Maine yeah is it nice
awesome I'd love to go great golf
oh but just the nature is it like the
Montana of the East Coast sign me up
winners suck though yeah that's like
Montana
well that's pretty much it for current
events that's it yeah we just got one
fight I guess this weekend you got a
fight night this weekend uh uh it's at
12 Pacific yep 12 in the afternoon
problem with this UFC pairs card it's a
good it's actually a really good uh
fight night it's a great fight night and
at noon how could you be mad at it
they're competing with the the college
football though my C bus play at 9 A.M
Pacific time baby TCU you also got Ohio
State player you got Tennessee Alabama
you got so many good games going down in
bet with DraftKings promo code job show
uh UFC Paris you have going down your
main event you had Cyril gone versus
Sergey Spivak
he got uh how do you pronounce her name
uh firat Virat man in fioro I believe
Fiero yeah I believe Tia silent I do
believe it's the same pan or pan
pharaoh and Rose is going down Rose went
up a weight class so first fight at
flyweight didn't do her any favors
didn't this is a tough fight for RO
she's also an underdog in this
which is interesting right she's a dog
in this fight
um let's see here she's a minus 185
she's gone up so yeah man infuro is so
Rose is plus 154. so just for you
non-betters out there if about 100 you
win 154 dollars
if you bet 200 you win 308 dollars
my math is already lost
yeah 208 yeah that's right
um but overall it's a good card you get
some some youngsters on there
see what's popping here
uh yeah the main event here's the thing
with Sarah gone and Sergey Spivak
um obviously it's a battle of styles
battle Clash of styles Sarah wants to
sit on the outside pick him apart
clearly best footwork in the game and
then with Spivak he's gonna want to get
in tight get him against the cage and
get look for takedowns with a submission
or TKO either said than done against guy
like Sergey unless your name's Jon Jones
the only caveat here is any guy that's
ever tried to take Sarah gone down has
been successful Francis ingano Jon Jones
also cerrogan's also coming off that
horrendous loss to Jon Jones where he's
embarrassed and for the heavyweight
title and it's also in his backyard in
Paris a lot of pressure on Cyril gone uh
he's never been manhandled like that uh
like Jon Jones even the Francis fight
that was a decision don't get twisted
that was a decision
um Jon Jones that fight wasn't even
remotely competitive so we're gonna find
out a lot about Cyril gone is he gonna
be still contenders can be a pretender
because he loses spivack this Road's
over this this Journey's over
um I think Cyril gets it done Cyril's a
slight favorite I can see why people
want to bet on Spivak on this
um you're assuming that serial God's
Jiu-Jitsu and grappling is that turibla
that's my French trebla
um but I think uh serial gun is going to
show up and show out I think he gets it
done via TKO in the third round
uh for the rose is a tough one she's
been gone a hot second she's going up
awake class uh it's not like she was big
for the other weight class uh she's come
off uh split lost decision with Carlos
sparza
but remember bro this is the same rose
that beat Zhang waylay who everybody
wants to suck on her titties right now
um
was so high on Zhang is all I'm saying
dude he wants to suck them tits
um so for waylay she's the she you know
the pound for pound goat right rose beat
her twice one was a walk-off KO head
kick in the first round that being said
waylay has gotten so much better since
2021. it's insane I'll get her
grapplings got it's insane from those
days she's so damn good
um
ah maybe it's my bias I I want to lean
towards Rose but again they're not doing
any favors here at all at all Fior is a
is bigger she's good at everything uh
she's big for the weight class Rose is
coming up Rose it's always depends where
mental game's at she's talking about
retiring talk about not retiring
um
yeah look at Pharaoh's record dog insane
she hasn't lost since 2018. she's
undefeating the UFC I wonder why they're
doing this to Rose
I think didn't Rose want to go up though
that's her no she wanted to go up but
you got to give her her can she get her
can you get her beak wet yeah yeah she's
gonna give her this girl's undefeated in
the UFC 10-1
the good thing is maybe they're doing it
because she plays this you know she wins
by decisions she's a decision girl
you know what I'm gonna take Rose
I'm gonna take Rose as the dog
I'll take roses the dog
uh your Surefire fight that's gonna end
in a KO would be the third fight the
main card owes the mayor and Gustav
Gustav that's a fun one
again this thing's not gonna blow your
hair back but for a fight night it's
pretty good three fights for sure I want
to see
sure yeah yeah
at least next week you got Saturday you
have UFC pay-per-view Australia and
we're doing a fight command Mr Joe Rogan
no Eddie Bravo Eddie Bravo's gonna be in
Japan so we we sent out the bat signal
and we got Sam tripley so yeah Joe Rogan
Sam Trip Lee Brian the kid count and
myself that is next Saturday for Izzy
for Sean Strickland which we'll break
down next week you'll see 293. that
card's not great either for Bayview that
thing is terrible let's be completely
transparent here top two look good
oh the tougher brother Justin Justin
Austin Lane that's a rematch yep Pedro
never mad at
olberg never mad at Jack Jenkins not mad
at
Malarkey one of my faves okay it's not
bad I'm just but compared to the last
pay-per-views that's all it is yeah but
in Australia like Izzy's on there shut
your mouth like yeah you're fair enough
Izzy Sean stricken's a fascinating fight
do you give Strickland
any chance at all
I do because Sean Strickland um
he's so tough to put away
couldn't be a worse matchup for him
I'm done with the days just being like
oh this is easy easy win like with the
sugar uh and sternum I was like this is
a nightmare for sugar yeah but these
guys there's there's just something
about them where that's their time
that's their moment that's their rise
into super stardom and it's just suggest
time so it's like on paper there's no
reason shookers should win this fight
I'm sorry there's no reason why Sean
Strickland should win this fight there's
just not he he gets it done with cardio
his Pace his volume he's not a knockout
artist you know he's not the most
technical guy but that's his thing
pacing boxing he does the Philly you
know shell his hands are low he's not
great at like cakes when he did go
against Elite Striker he got absolutely
starch and oxpiera
so all markers indicate is he's going to
absolutely destroy him it's MMA that's
why this is the worst sport to make
picks and and put your money on the
sport it's insane so who knows but Izzy
should win Is He To Me the greatest
we've seen so especially coming off the
Alex Pierre fight also the UFC didn't
want to book this fight and Izzy tell
them book and I'll take care of this guy
there's a lot of confidence in Izzy too
so you never know also we haven't really
seen Sean Strickland grapple
bisping's worked with him says Duke and
grapple his ass off we just don't see it
and I assume Sean Strickland now I'm
breaking this fight down but I'm
assuming Sean Strickland learned from
the ax Pierre fight isn't going to play
those games with Izzy
you know yeah who knows Strickland's a
Madman
I'm excited for the press conference
yeah who knows what the hell he's gonna
say by the way we didn't actually talk
about this right the pierra and Anthony
Smith or do we uh I mean I allude to a
little bit how uh Pierre was mad at us
at uh Anthony Smith you know this this
issue though Pierre he gets mad a lot of
these you know people like me and stuff
like that you
me and him had an issue hey man know
your background but with uh I mean come
on Doug but uh with Pierre ticket Matt
Anthony Smith remember he's a he's a
analyst yeah
so he was actually when I heard him
talking about me too he was like he was
like yeah the guy is you know technical
great Striker great Striker so but maybe
he needs that fuel to get to get him
going you know um so I I don't put too
much into it I just don't get why he
pays attention to this stuff
like like Anthony Smith he is the actual
commentator do you get mad at Rogan if
they say anything that not super
complimentary to get mad DC like that's
literally their job now maybe for
Anthony it's different because he's
currently fighting in the same division
but that's that fight's not next for
Alex now if Anthony wins one more and
Alex wins you know against Yuri
Anthony could get it done and there's a
story here so maybe that's why he's
doing it I don't know I don't know but I
don't get why they get mad when a guy's
literally paid to comment on fighting
and get mad when he comments on fighting
and didn't say anything terrible no it
wasn't bad at all so it's a reach there
is that it that's pretty much it dude
all right kids first one first live one
in the books a few uh stand up dates for
your Covina California Covina is next
Friday one show I'm sorry one night only
two shows Brian Kellen myself we're back
together for the first time ever
co-headlining Covina California Covina
Laugh Factory it's a little theater out
there in Covina one of my favorite
venues that's September 8th that's next
Friday two shows I think seven and nine
forty five me and Brian together because
that Saturday September 9th will be in
Austin Texas doing a JRE live for Izzy
ver Strickland Spokane Washington again
one of my favorite clubs Spokane
Washington September 21st to the 23rd
I'm in Vegas at skank Fest September
29th through October 1st I'm doing a
million shows there so just look for it
uh then we just added Iowa to beat Dube
Dubuque Dubuque Dubuque Iowa October
13th through 14th that's one show Friday
one show Saturday then Niagara Falls and
then Chicago just announced to December
8th and 9th that's two shows Friday two
shows Saturday that's in Chicago but uh
Covina I'll see you next week and then
it's Spokane fair Club Spokane come get
you some September 21st 21st through
September 23rd uh tickets at thick
boy.com that's it we live thank you for
watching subscribing leave a comment do
your thing share post uh appreciate guys
every Monday we will be live at 9 00 a.m
moving forward so uh thank you guys for
tuning in thanks for the support thanks
for watching be nice to each other until
next time I'm out